hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to freddy fazbear's
pizzeria simulator now i've been playing
this game in a way that
some might misconstrue as being
illogical
horrifying and death defying but
that's the only way that i can play this
game and still call myself the king of
five nights at freddy's
because there's an easy way to play this
game you can play with no risk
always tossing the scrap back out in the
yard but i
i don't play that [ __ ] i play the tough
way because i take the hard road no
matter what it is and i'm gonna beat
this thing
with all of the heart inside my soul
there also
are some secrets inside the games
themselves like this fruit maze game
and this racer game have secrets inside
them i can't play them right now because
i have no play tokens
so i'm going to see to the end of the
game right now if this is the end of the
game that i'm about to see
and then hopefully i'm going to be able
to get to more of the secrets
later or get something done
so here we go i gotta go into this with
a lot of concentration
i know that it's not gonna go well for
me but that's fine
because i have the eye of the tiger and
the ears of a hawk
and everything is in my power to be to
be able to do this
because i know exactly when you're
crawling on my own ass
and i know exactly how to get you out of
there
hey no stop that right now
you stop that you go back you go back
you go back
we can do this if we're just extremely
patient
hey welcome to the party ah
come on i should have known i'd find you
i shouldn't have known [ __ ] you just
snuck up on me you piece of poo
i hear him coming down both ends i think
i do
i think it's fine
oh okay so there's a noise
there's a noise for them just walking
outside the hall and there's a noise for
them actually getting in the vent
and i got to differentiate between those
two noises
[Music]
hey how's it going don't mind lally and
me screaming me screaming has nothing to
do with lally
that's got nothing to do with you so you
get out of here or dumb
heard something something or something
you may not recognize me at first but i
assure you
that's still me oh
i don't know which way to go
okay
[Music]
no no no no no no no hey how's it going
you didn't hear anything about no pool
ward pace did you
you wouldn't know anything about that
being a dirty stinking animatronic
maybe i'm an animatronic if you wouldn't
stop shutting up
oh come on
okay oh i heard that again
let me see okay not in the event not in
the van i'm
it's fine it's fine it's fine
i can't tell
i don't i didn't hear anything i didn't
hear anything for definite certain but i
don't
where are you i'm nowhere huh no
i heard that heard that heard that no no
oh hey how's it going there friend you
scurry on back
you go back you go back
okay oh there's one right there
i didn't finish that task but that's
okay because in the face of death i'll
take anything as solace
real good we're so good
the goodness that we have inside our
hearts all of the goodness shining out
through our
faces with light and shining brightness
beautiful
goodness far as you i can see
fascinating oh oh oh oh
i don't know what you're doing but you
need to stop now
okay
the noisy-ass posters are the worst ones
huh
ah don't not now not now no no okay
okay okay just one more complex task and
then we're good
we can get the hecky outta here and then
we got the simple ones
squonk along go leave me alone
please please i'm begging you
i'm baking you i'm begging strip ya
i'm gonna bacon begging strips yeah i'll
give you a begging strip
if you don't wolf woof over here oh
that's not good
oh you know what oh i ain't worth the
risk
wait why why oh no no no not now none no
no no stop no no no no
no i'm not also any friend of death
you stay away from me
huh
[Music]
no no not like this
not like this i gotta do something about
it
okay i'm fine
i don't hear anything i don't hear
anything
i'm so good at this game look how good i
am guys you played right into our hands
did i
did you really think that this job just
fell out of the sky for you
no no no
this was a gift for us
you gathered them all together in one
place
just like he asked you to okay good good
greg
all of those little souls in one
place great good great just for
us okay a gift
now we can do what we were created to do
yeah
and be complete i will make you proud
daddy
watch listen
and be full
connection terminated i'm sorry to
interrupt you elizabeth
if you still even remember that name but
i'm afraid you've been misinformed
you are not here to receive a gift nor
have you been called here by the
individual you assume
although you have indeed been called
you have all been called here into a
labyrinth of sounds and smells
misdirection and misfortune a labyrinth
with no exit
amazed with no prize you don't even
realize that you are trapped
your lust for blood has driven you in
endless circles
chasing the cries of children in some
unseen chamber always seeming so near
it's somehow out of reach but you will
never find them
none of you will this is where your
story ends
and to you my brave volunteer who
somehow found this job listing
not intended for you although there was
a way out planned for you
i have a feeling that's not what you
want i have a feeling that you are
right where you want to be i am
remaining as well
i am nearby this place will not be
remembered
and the memory of everything that
started this
can finally begin to fade away as the
agony of
every tragedy should and to you monsters
trapped in the corridors
be still and give up your spirits they
don't belong to you
for most of you i believe there is peace
and perhaps more
waiting for you after the smoke clears
although for one of you
the darkest pit of hell has opened to
swallow you whole
so don't keep the devil waiting for
friend
my daughter if you can hear me i knew
you would return as well
it's in your nature to protect the
innocent i'm sorry that on that day
the day you were shut out and left to
die
no one was there to lift you up into
their arms the way you lifted
others into yours and then what became
of you
i should have known you wouldn't be
content to disappear not
my daughter i couldn't save you then so
let me save you now
it's time to rest for you and for those
you have carried
in your arms this ends for all of us
in communication
congratulations on completing your work
week we apologize if your situation
wasn't presented to you in a completely
honest fashion when you first started
but it was important that your
intentions and actions be genuine
here at fazbear entertainment we value
fun family and food
but more importantly we value our
commitment to atoning for past mistakes
and tying up loose ends thank you for
your participation
there is no need for you to return to
work next week as fazbear entertainment
is no longer a corporate entity
please accept this certificate of
completion goodbye for now
and thank you for taking this journey
with us what
oh i just got a pain through my heart
was that the end of everything
oh my god
[Music]
was that the end of everything
molten freddy tutorial unit cassette man
wow i think that's really it
because that wrapped up like a lot of
actual lore that gave
actual answers
[Music]
that was incredible
that was really fun and this game is
free by the way i don't know if i ever
said that this game
that i'm playing is free it's
scott
wow sky
that's i'm really really touched and
heartbroken too because that's the end
of it
and i think this is yeah this is the end
i think this is like the end
now i'm not i know i'm certain there are
other mysteries to be
told but i think this as far as the five
nights at freddy's story
like main story probably goes i think
this probably wraps up everything this
this ties it all up in a bow and man
there it is
there you have it it's crazy
i guess that's it is there anything more
there's like there there also are the
secrets of
the the mini games inside of it like the
various things even the candy robot
apparently that does tell you stories if
you if you do
go into that now you could go through
this game and you could play it like
getting
more money with less risk and that's
always a possibility but at the same
time
oh certificate to completion what other
certificates are there
what other certificates i want to know
ah i want to know
god uh but that was really cool i gotta
admit that was
really really cool it was something that
was different from the whole five nights
at freddy's experience as we know it but
in a way it fits so well like the the
simulator aspect of it the weirdness and
the
funniness like that's what it is it's
not like these games aren't like solely
divided into
scariness and uh thrill and like
mystery and theories it's it's a mixture
of all of it and that's what made five
nights at freddy's so magical in the
first place is that it was
a fun satirical dry humor and it
it also was extremely terrifying and
it's that perfect
mixture that always made five nights at
freddy's so
wonderful and this game really captured
it leaning more on the silliness but
actually leaning really heavy into the
darker tones of it
it bridged this gap really nicely and i
really enjoyed that but before i go i'm
gonna see what happens if i hit continue
on this and see where that leads me is
this it's saturday
ah okay so i think i just go through it
again so that's not what it is
so i'm gonna leave this at this and uh
maybe i will try to beat the other
modes but thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for joining me on
this journey of five nights at freddy's
i know that five nights at freddy's will
not be over in the horse of the fans and
maybe even scott will make more five
nights at freddy's games in the future
but as far as the main story goes i
think that is a
really nice conclusion to answer a lot
of unanswered questions and get that out
there so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down the
comments below
let me know if you want to see more of
this and me to dive into the deeper
mysteries of it
and as always i will see you
in the next video
[Music]
um
foreign
you